ja ich begrüße alle zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer heute geht es um platons
berühmtes sonnen gleichnis
wer war platon zunächst ein paar
informationen zu seiner person so sieht
er aus platons ein antiker griechischer
philosoph und lebte im fünften und
vierten vorchristlichen jahrhundert in
athen vor allem wo er auch eine akademie
hatte
entwickelte seine philosophie
überwiegend im philosophischen dialogen
und gleichnissen und um ein gleichnis
soll es auch heute gehen eines der
berühmtesten gleichnisse ist das
sogenannte sonnen gleichnis daneben hat
blasen aber auch noch ein linien
gleichnis und ein höhlengleichnis
entworfenen dieses bild stammt von
wikipedia
jetzt gehen wir auf die analogie
zwischen auge und sondern ein bisschen
näher ein was ist darunter zu verstehen
man das auge ja mal die sonne wie können
wir das genauer bestimmen von platon ist
alles was mit dem sehen zu tun hat sehr
sehr philosophisch bedeutsam auch das
wort idee kritisch idee hatte
ursprünglich die bedeutung etwas gesehen
haben also wir wissen dann etwas wenn
wir es gesehen habe
jetzt gibt es hier eine analogie
zwischen dem auge und der sonne wie
sieht das aus die sonne ist zwar mich
das auge sagt dieser dialogpartner in
dem sich das sein gleiches befindet bei
platten aber das auge ist am sonnigsten
von allen unseren sinnesorgan als wenn
die sonne in das sehen etwas besonders
ausgezeichnet ist dann ist auch das auge
besonders groß gezeigt weil es am
sonntag exten ist wir könnten uns nach
dem geruchssinn vorstellung den hörsinn
aber nach platon ist das auge das jenige
sinnesorgan fast am wichtigsten was uns
am meisten wissen vermittelt
das auge und jetzt kommt die analogie
ihre das verhältnis zusammen das auge
kann nur deswegen sehen weil es die
sonne gibt die sonne spendet im auge das
licht oder anders gesagt die sonne
eröffnet überhaupt den raum dafür dass
wir sehen können das als eine sehr
wichtige bedingung für das sehen im
dunkeln sieht das auge nichts die sonne
ist also sagt jetzt platt um die ursache
des sehens und sie wird aber auch vom
auge gesehen es wird also ein
interessanter bezug zwischen beiden
statt jetzt können wir dieses gleichnis
noch ein bisschen weiter entwickeln und
zwar wenn wir es auf die seele
anwenden also unser auge jetzt
übertragen auf die seele die funktion
genauso wie sich das auge auf die sonne
richten kann richtet sich die seele auf
das was wissen vermittelt nicht das was
wir sehen können was wird durch der
sehen erkennen können sind das dass wir
durch das denken erkennt so wie sich das
auge auf die sonne richten muss um etwas
sehen zu können so muss ich die seele
auf das nennen was uns überhaupt
erkennen lässt im reinen denken das ist
nach platin dasjenige was er die idee
des guten etwas was wir erkennen können
durch die idee des guten sind die ideen
gehen sie jetzt so wie das auge sich auf
das dunkle richten können wenn sich auch
die seele auf das dunkle riecht das
dunkle sind dieser ebene dieser gleiches
ebene das werbende und dafür gehen dann
wenn sie sich darauf wichtig dann
erkennen sie nicht sie bleibt den bloßen
meinungen verfangen
also das werden und vergehen des platon
immer etwas was nicht wirklich im
strengen sinne existiert weil es neben
nicht konstant ist wir können es nicht
richtig fassen das sind pleite
die idee des guten ist also die gleichen
ebene zur sonne zug auf die seele sowie
die sonne bezogen auf das auge die idee
des guten ist das sinnige dass jetzt die
mehr kanten wahrheit verbleibt und dem
erkennenden das für zu erkennen also wie
das eine bedingung wie die sonne für das
auge diesem rahmen eröffnet so die idee
des guten für das erkennen den
erkenntnis raum jetzt können wir diese
analogien noch ein bisschen war enger
fassen nämlich zwischen idee des guten
und der sonne die idee dass bogen um die
sonne gleichen sich nach plan denn die
sonne verleiht dem gesehenen nicht nur
die sichtbarkeit sondern auch das
wachsen und gedeihen ohne da sich die
soll dabei selbst verändert also die
sonne ist nicht nur der erkenntnis grund
bis gesehenen wir können das nicht
machen nicht nur wegen der sonne sehen
sind das gesehene existiert auch nur
wegen der sonne als auch designs grund
und dabei verändert sich die sonne nicht
scheint also die sonne bleibt stabil und
ist nichts was dem werden und es
entstehen unterlegte sehen wir natürlich
heute in der modernen naturwissenschaft
anders die sonne
ist entstanden und vergeht auch in ein
paar milliarden jahren auch den
erkannten jetzt auf diese übertragungs
eben mit dem erkannten die durch die
seele kommt die nur sein und
wirklichkeit zu weil es an der idee des
kunden teil hat alles da in einer ganz
engen beziehung dazu steht die idee des
guten sagt baden zum schluss die
übersteigt sogar die wirklichkeit da sie
diese erkennen und entstehen lassen das
was der erkenntnis und der science grund
einer sache ist muss noch über dieses
jahr hinaus gehen da die wirklichkeit
hier durch die idee des guten erkannt
wird und erzeugt wird entstehen kann
muss die idee des guten über die
wirklichkeit hinausgehen sie muss die
möglichkeit tanz zitieren